Come up to you. I had this
guy on yesterday, this guy
who wrote this book, uh,
El Narcos name is Yuan Grillo and he's a,
he's an investigative journalist who
lives in Mexico and he studies the cartel,
they show organs. And this is one of
the things he was saying was that they,
they get these people used to killing
and they were getting in these kids and
then having these kids kill at a young
age and dismember people and they were
doing it to get fear out of their body.
So this one guy who was,
they had a nickname for him,
Tyson. He would, he was a cop,
but he was also in charge of hiring these
little kids and training these little
kids to be assassins. And he would
teach them how to dismember people.
And he was going into it
and all the things they did
and all the beheadings that
they did.
And he was saying that they'd try to
that in certain certain groups of people
when they have this organization, they
try to get them used to horrific acts.
Well, it's called the, she meant a blood
and that's a Heinrich Himmler term.
Uh, head of the ash ash ish that the
ash ash, she'll, Hitler had about seven,
eight years.
We launched a war show.
He got like 12 year olds ready for war
and they would get them like having fun
and swimming and working out at boxing
and then they would like on there like 15
give super hot hooker and then give
them drugs, LSD to get discovered.
Switzerland. Hitler was to put
them all on DMT, everything.
And they will then have these religious
experiences and say you're invincible,
you're superman.
This has all been declassified.
But it should more esoteric writings
and so they would get, I'm all wound up.
And then to graduate as an SS officer.
After you'd had a dog like five years,
you had to strangle your German shepherd.
Yeah, that was a, my friend Ari.
His Dad was in the Israeli special
forces or one of those one brands.
Would you remember what branch was?
One branch of the Israeli military
and they had to kill a kitten.
They had a run and like, like, look,
Jews are just like anybody else.
There's good people, there's
bad people. But yeah,
Israel because they got so screwed by the
Nazis and a lot of sickening ways just
kind of copied a lot of it. And by the
way, the policies are trying to kill them,
blow them up.
I'm not even,
my point is just that the Nazis got
evil down so much that like we brought
34,000 in the run, NASA, the run,
the university's operation paperclip,
everybody wanted Nazis.
They were learning.
They were like winning the lottery
because they were all robots and we do
whatever they were told. Well
one of Bron was absolutely, yeah,
just head honors and he was
a Nazi show show, show it.
What happened was first they gave him
a shacks. They gave him power. They,
they would really press room.
You had to go through things and then,
uh,
they would basically,
you'll just condition them to
do whatever they were told.
And they call it the cement
of blood because then, uh,
it's just like satanic cults say,
you know, kill your dog. I mean,
I remember when I was growing
up in Rockwall, Texas,
I ran into like a state
and call. I was like, God,
this girl's a senior in high school.
She's super hot. I'm an, I'm an, I'm in a,
I'm in ninth grade and like she's picking
me up in her Mercedes and I'm taking
me some mansion and the
sexual there is incredible.
And I'm walking out of the house cause
I looked like I was about 16 when I was
13 and the dad goes, he likes screwing
my daughter. Yeah, I screw or two. Whoa.
I just, as soon as you
join us, love Lucifer,
you get all of them will tell you
want boy, cause we want you. But,
but oh yeah,
but that's yeah.
Then I have an incredible life
look also do now you're looking at,
but the point is, is that Yo Kelly,
you're in La, you know about all this,
but the point is,
is still battle that the point is,
is that then the satanist is that
ever really gotten to say this?
And they said well, they said, well what
do you want? Cause I don't want to be,
we want you to kill your dog.
Whoa.
And so the point is is that now all these
years later kill a loving thing that
serves you, cares about
you. This interface.
Dogs are very psychic or psyche buffers.
Dogs are able to like interface with
you and they want you to take something
that's way to die for you and
they want you to kill that.
That's like killing a child. A dog is
very similar to child, very spiritual,
very holy. You a very good dog will take
on its masters aura. It can be evil.
But John just totally spilling my guts.
Church people need to know about all
those and this is what's going on and this
is what's happening and show.
So they want the submit a blood is they
get people in a group and they get them
to do horrible evil things
during peer pressure.
And then they create the synthesis.
You have to know the darker elements of
the criminal networks that are inside
our government are actually running Mexico
as a laboratory test cause they know
native Americans are taking,
Americans aren't Gung Ho.
And they're tough and they're
ready to hide. Not, you know,
I'm part native American long,
like 6% Comanche and you know, uh,
Texas and just that
little bit makes me wild.
And so they can get them cause they're
powerful. They're smart, they're neat,
they're cool. But genetically
they go into group think really,
really fast. And so native Americans,
you can mind control really fast.
Hmm. Why is that? Well,
it's like Vietnam. I mean,
you know, the, the, the, the, the, the,
the Bering land straight
and basically the test,
the genetics of a Mezzo Mesoamerican
is basically Chinese or hunt.
Cause there was always some whites and
vikings even 10,000 years ago in the area.
Uh, but, uh,
like nobody in fights like
in Korea find the Chinese,
that's who we're really fighting. There
are Vietnam, these fricking, I mean,
they're like, they're, they're,
they're conscious and real people,
but when they get into a fight,
they all sync up and our
robots and have no fear of,
you're not about psychotic killers,
you're fighting.
And so Asians or by about
the most fearless killers
there are like the Mongols,
any of them. I mean, once Asians go
to war, it's like they do not there.
It's in fact they're not even
crazy going wild in a battle.
They're like robots coming to kill you.
And so do you think that's from,
do you think that's from the heritage
of war? That they have a long list?
Like if you think about Japan,
Japan has a long history of being a noble
warrior culture with the Samurais and
well it's called the Marshall from the
nobility. It's the genetics, right?
But are the genetics is what creates that?
Yo,
it's like 500 of you load and planes.
[inaudible] what I'm saying is think
about a place like Japan were so much
martial arts came from Kendo
sword fighting a karate
above a bunch of different
branches of crowded judo, Jujitsu, Japan,
all that stuff came from
Japan. I mean that, that,
that is a group of people that were
obsessed with combat. I mean they,
they figured out a long class wash.
Well,
not just that the soldiers and
even the civilian. No, I agree.
But the ruling class was Samurai. Yeah.
Shoguns the ruling class was a shoguns.
Right.
And when you think about what a small
place Japan is and how stunning it is that
so much innovation, especially in terms
of like, what am I gonna work martial,
don't get a bell curve because you've
got black people that are smart as any
white person. And then he got black
people that are way better at sports,
whatever, that there are
genetic differences. We're not.
Then you've got the head of your former,
you know it was cold springs harbor.
Watson comes out and says blacks
aren't human, all that Bs.
That's just the racist crap. It's in the
government. But it's true that northern,
some groups are northern Europeans and
then the Japanese on average per capita
of the arch Iq. And so
they're, they're Japanese.
And then there are some northern
Europeans that have the highest Iq,
but then you can get into like say Jews
have very high accused. On average,
he and Jews have an extraordinary
high level social trials winners.
It's a bunch of, so there's not just one
type of intelligence. Yeah. Oh, for sure.
Yeah. Well, there's, there's, I mean,
there's tests that you can
run in terms of mathematics,
but there's no real tests you can
run in terms of social intelligence,
psychic connectivity,
and they've proven the DNA is a
transceiver and show my skill is,
that's why I'm usually kind of like almost
autistic is I'm just being constantly
like, everything's going on,
but then it actually focused in,
I can like figure out the
exact enemy operation.
That's why they were really pissed.